en este vídeo vamos a jugar con la
región que tenemos entre estas dos
funciones entre la función y es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de xy la función y es
igual a x cuadrada y la vamos a girar
pero en esta ocasión no alrededor del
eje de las 10 en esta ocasión vamos a
girar la alrededor de una recta vertical
la recta x igual a 2
y bueno si ustedes hacen el sólido de
revolución que les queda al girar esta
región alrededor de esta recta les va a
quedar esta figura que yo tengo aquí
esta figura que tiene esta cierta forma
extraña y es una figura que tiene un
hoyo en el centro un hoyo que se forma
por la función y es igual x cuadrada y
entonces parece ser como una pared y
bueno para sacar el volumen de esta
pared voy a utilizar el método de las
arandelas otra vez que al final es
utilizar el método de los discos pero
como un método de los discos con anillos
por eso también es conocido como el
método de los anillos y bueno como lo
que queremos es girar alrededor de esta
línea vertical entonces lo que vamos a
querer es tener un buen de arandelas y
sin embargo estas grandes van a tener
tener una función de iu porque lo que
vamos a querer hacer es sumar estas
arandelas e integrar con respecto a y si
tenemos estas arandelas por lo tanto
este que voy a dibujar aquí es un radio
interno que por cierto si se dan cuenta
está definido por la función y es igual
a x cuadrada y también tenemos un rato
exterior que va a ser este de aquí y que
por cierto está definido por la función
y es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x y se
los juro que estoy intentando ser el
mejor dibujo más razonablemente posible
y después tenemos un cierto grosor de
este anillo recuerden que el grosor es
muy importante el cual es un pequeño muy
pequeño de 10 así que déjenme darle
volumen y por lo tanto dibujar el grosor
y ya he acabado con esto ya tenemos aquí
a mi arandela y bueno esta arandela que
les acabo de dibujar es justo la
arandela que sale si yo roto alrededor
de esta recta x igualados este
rectángulo que les voy a dibujar aquí
este rectángulo tiene como altura de
james y lo estamos girando alrededor de
la recta vertical x igualados con esto
es que obtenemos a nuestra arandela
y bueno ya que tenemos ahora a nuestra
arandela lo que voy a construir es una
arandela para cada uno de los valores de
que en este intervalo y por lo tanto
puedes imaginarte a un montón de
arandelas y el volumen de este sólido de
revolución va a ser la suma de todos los
volúmenes de todas estas arandelas
recuerden que tomábamos el límite
diciendo que day era muy pequeño y por
lo tanto teníamos una infinidad de
arandelas eso dicho en otras palabras
quiere decir que day es
infinitesimalmente pequeño pero bueno
antes de emocionarnos con todo esto lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es sacar
el volumen de una de las arandelas y
para sacar el volumen de unas de esas
arandelas lo que voy a necesitar es que
el volumen sea una función de y para
empezar lo que voy a hacer es escribir
estas dos funciones como funciones de
james en la función demorado me queda
que es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x y
si yo paso la raíz cuadrada del otro
lado entonces me va a quedar que x o la
función de lleva a ser igual a ye
cuadrada ese es nuestra función exterior
la función que tenemos en la pared
exterior y ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es
lo que pasa con la función interior
es decir con la función de amarillo y es
igual a equis cuadrada y si yo saco raíz
de ambos lados entonces me va a quedar
que por cierto estoy sacando la raíz
principal y eso es muy cierto porque
esta función vive en nuestro primer
cuadrante y entonces ahora sí si yo saco
la raíz principal de ambos lados me
queda que x es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de james bueno ahora la pregunta es ya
que tengo el grosor de jane de este
estarán de la cual es el área de esta
arandela vamos a tomar el color
anaranjado y entonces el área que es una
función de ella va a ser igual a quien
pues claro ya lo hemos visto
va a ser el área del círculo que estamos
considerando en la función exterior ya
ésta le vamos a quitar el área del
círculo de la función interior es decir
le vamos a quitar el agujero de enmedio
así que el círculo exterior quien es
pues de spi por radio al cuadrado y por
el radio exterior elevado al cuadrado ya
esto le tenemos que quitar el área de la
circunferencia interior déjenme volver a
escribirlo de esta siguiente manera pi
que multiplica al radio exterior elevado
al cuadrado
y que multiplica al radio interior
elevado al cuadrado y queremos que esta
sea una función que solamente dependa de
gemma entonces empecemos a ver al radio
exterior pero el radio exterior tiene
que ser una función de james y fíjense
bien el radio exterior es toda esta
distancia que tenemos aquí toda la
distancia que hay de la función exterior
hasta la recta vertical x igualados es
decir toda la distancia que hay desde la
recta x igualados hasta llegar a la
función exterior que era igual a equis
cuadrada hoy ha visto como una función
de james x igual a ye cuadrada y si lo
queremos ver en términos de x sería
todos menos cualquier valor que x valga
aquí sin embargo como no queremos ver
todo en términos de ya que al final es
lo mismo entonces va a ser 2 - la
función de y que la función de l es
igual a de cuadrada por lo tanto que me
va a quedar por lo tanto al escribirlo
aquí me queda 2 - la función del
exterior que es cuadrada 2 menos de
cuadrada perdón
- ya cuadrada 2 - cuadrada y ahora es
hora de fijarnos en el radio interior el
radio interior va a ser igual a quien y
haciendo una analogía va a ser
exactamente lo mismo es la distancia de
la recta x igualados hasta la función
exterior es decir la función efe
igual a la raíz cuadrada de james si lo
vemos solamente en términos pensado en
valores de x va a ser el valor de x
igualados que es el que toma la recta
menos cualquier valor que tome x en la
función
efe igual a la raíz de ella y por lo
tanto ya puedo escribir yo mi radio
interior como 2 - la función interior de
ya que es la raíz cuadrada de jeff ahora
sí ahora sí ya que tenemos el radio
interior y el radio exterior pues lo que
vamos a hacer es sustituir todo en la
fórmula del área entonces y factor hizo
yo a piqué me va a quedar y que
multiplica a el radio exterior elevado
al cuadrado por el radio exterior es 2 -
ya cuadrada y todo esto elevado al
cuadrado menos y que va a multiplicar a
quien a buen dicen a la función interior
elevada al cuadrado por la función
interiores 2 menos
y elevado al cuadrado y bueno esta base
entonces mi fórmula del área ya escrita
todo en términos de james si yo lo que
quiero sacar es el volumen de esta
arandela entonces tengo que multiplicar
el área por el grosor pero el grosor
habíamos dicho que era de iu entonces
este grosor este pequeño y delgado y
diminuto grosor es de james entonces
para sacar el volumen de esta arandela
hay que multiplicar todo esto por de
james y después lo que vamos a hacer es
tomarnos la suma de todas estas
arandelas por lo tanto eso se escribe
como la integral de dónde a dónde hay
que fijarnos en los límites de
integración y como es una función de
yale lo que hay que fijarnos es en
límites de integración que tengan que
ver con valores de y por lo tanto son
dos puntos que puntos este punto que
tenemos aquí que es el origen y el otro
punto que tenemos aquí arriba vamos a
sacarlos y para esto tenemos que igualar
las dos funciones es decir en qué
momento la raíz de jay y de cuadradas lo
mismo y si hacemos un poco de memoria es
en 0 y en 1 y entonces estos dos valores
de 10 son mis límites de integración por
lo tanto ya tengo que la integral de 0 a
1 de todo esto que tengo aquí
diferencial de james es
quién va a ser el volumen de mis sólidos
de revolución que estoy buscando el
volumen de esta forma rara por ahorita
los dejo aquí pero en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a resolver esta integral